Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today, I’m
going to explain an American science
fiction film called “The Time Machine.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The premise of the film is set in 1899. Dr.
Alexander Hartdegen is an associate professor
of applied mechanics and engineering at Columbia
University. The movie starts as we see him working
on a formula, so much invested that his friend and
colleague, David Philby, has to remind him of his
date with his girlfriend Emma at 5. Hearing this,
Alexander quickly picks his notes and rushes back
to his house to get ready. On his way, he and
David talk about all of Alex’s proposals that
the University has rejected. David suggests
he make his proposals less radical for them,
to make them useful for humans. At Alex’s home,
they are greeted by his housekeeper, Mrs. Watchit.
They make Alex get into fancy new clothes and
he leaves to meet Emma. He finally meets Emma,
the two walk in the central park talking. Alex
brings up his deteriorating health, and claims
he will only be good again when she marries him.
Emma, with teary eyes, accepts his proposal.
After a little hassling through his pockets, he
gives her a ring with her birthstone embedded
in it. Emma is over the moon. However, a man
suddenly approaches them and circles around.
He asks them for their money; when Alex tries to
retaliate, the mugger points his gun at him.
Alex complies and gives the mugger his wallet
and watch, but when he asks for Emma’s ring,
they deny it. The man then tries to snatch it
from her, and shoots her dead while struggling.
Alex holds her in his arms calling her name,
while she takes her last breath and dies. He
is beyond devastated as he hugs her limp corpse
and cries in vain. The scene cuts to four years
later. Alex is writing a formula on the board,
researching something like he always does. He has
still not been able to get over Emma’s death, and
has been busy with his work ever since. David and
Mrs. Watchit are worried for him. That day when
David comes to meet him, he notices something on
the other side of the curtains and demands David
to tell him what he is working on. David invites
him for dinner in a week and offers to show him
his invention then. A week goes by, and it is
finally the day. Alex dresses himself up, for the
first time since Emma’s death. He then opens the
curtains and we see a piece of huge machinery on
the other side. It has many wheels and gears, in
the middle, a chair is embedded. Alex sits on it
and looks at Emma’s picture on a locket. He slowly
pulls down a lever, making a sphere shield around
him. The machine then puts itself in motion.
When Alex pulls down a final lever, the camera
zooms into a pocket watch and we see its hand
move in an anticlockwise direction. As it turns
out, the machine Alex is using is a time machine.
He has put his blood and sweat into the machine,
to go back to the day Emma died four years ago
and save her. In the following scene, we see
the future Alex in central park on the day of
Emma’s death. She sees him and runs towards him.
Alex is stunned to see his precious love back.
He kisses her in delight and runs her to the
nearest chariot to take her away from the park.
They get off the chariot in the middle of
the city. Alex tells her to go to her home
and stay there for the night. Assuming that the
past Alex will come to Emma’s home at night,
he tells her to not be confused and just remember
that he loves her. He leaves her by the side of
the road to get her flowers as he promised. But
then, a vehicle hits her, killing Emma again.
Alex realizes that he cannot change Emma’s fate
and no matter what he does, she will die that
night. But he doesn’t give up. He believes that
the people from the future have surely found a
way to alter this factor, so he decides to go into
the future and study futuristic time machines.
He gets into the machine and pulls down the lever
again, this time setting the time to 2030. As he
travels through time, he sees the world around
him changing. In 2030, he sees an advertisement
for a settlement being established on the moon.
He goes to the New York library, hoping to find
a book on time travel where he meets a hologram
of the librarian named Vox 114, and is stunned
by the technology. However, when he talks about
time travel, Vox 114 reveals that there hasn’t
been any invention of such sort. Thinking that he
would have better luck a couple of years later,
he gets into the machine again and now travels to
the year 2037. In 2037, the world has been fully
destroyed. The lunar habitation program has made
the earth inhabitable because the moon was pulled
closer to it. The gravitational forces of the
bodies change causing frequent earthquakes and
tsunamis on earth. The lunar habitation has caused
a huge crack on the surface of the moon.
Two policemen, who are evacuating the earth,
arrest Alex to take him to his evacuation center.
As he resists them, the ground
starts to shake and splits in half,
spilling out hot lava. Alex quickly gets into his
machine and drives away; but amidst the chaos,
hits his head on a piece of metal, making him go
unconscious. The time machine starts its journey,
but an unconscious Alex isn’t there to stop it.
When he finally opens his eyes, he sees that he
has reached the year 802,701, and quickly stops
the machine before falling unconscious again.
He wakes up in a bed with his wounds healed.
As he wears his clothes, a little boy approaches
him and runs away. Alex follows the kid and
sees that the future humans have reverted to
a primitive lifestyle and live on cliffs. They
all come to Alex and watch him in awe, but do
not seem to understand English, except for a girl
named Mara who can speak the language fluently.
Alex tells her that he is a time traveller, but
Mara tells the others he is just a wandering
fool so that they won’t kill him. Those people
are called the Elois. A loud honking is heard,
and everyone goes into their shed. That night, he
stays at Mara and her brother, Kalen’s place. He
sees the broken pieces of the moon in the sky.
The following day, Mara takes Alex to his time
machine. The two see that it has not been damaged.
Mara insists Alex take Kalen with him to the past.
Before Alex can ask why, loud honking is heard
in the background. Mara freaks out and runs to
save Kalen, as a confused Alex follows her.
Everyone around them starts running back to
the cliffs as well. Suddenly, Alex comes
face to face with a beast life creature.
They are called the Morlocks. More of them emerge
from the ground and start attacking everyone.
They tie the people they can get their
hands in, and take them into the ground.
Alex watches as one of them gets Mara and sinks
with her into the soil. When all of them are gone,
Alex tries asking the others where the Morlocks
take them, but Kalen tells him that when the Elois
are taken, they are not supposed to talk about
it. Kalen then takes Alex to the opening to the
world of the Morlocks. They climb down into a cave
and Alex realizes that it is the New York Library.
The hologram of Vox 144 talks from behind them.
Since the technology worked on solar power,
he has survived all these years. Alex is beyond
surprised, and asks him what is going on with
the world now. Vox 114 replies that the human
race has evolved into two, Elois and Morlocks.
This is the nature of the world now. The Morlocks
come to the surface to hunt Elois for survival.
Vox then reveals that to reach the world of
Morlocks, they should follow the ‘breathing’.
Kalen and Alex hear the noise and follow
it to reach a massive statue of a demonic
face whose mouth is an opening to Morlock's
world. He leaves Kalen outside and climbs
down underground carefully. He finally reaches
the place and sees a whole civilization there.
He then sneaks into a room, and accidentally
falls into a pond full of human remains.
Alex is then found by a Morlock and
sent into their leader’s chamber.
The leader explains, that when the moon
dissociated, some people sank under the ground
with nowhere else to go. Over the years,
they evolved into flesh-eating Morlocks.
Others miraculously survived on the surface
and repopulated, the Elois. The Morlocks
tried to come back to the surface, but couldn’t,
because of the years of underground evolution.
So they started to hunt the humans
from the surface for food and breeding.
The leader also reveals that he has the power
to control both Elois and Morlocks’ minds,
and controls the balance of the world through
them. He has also read Alex’s mind, and knows
that he is a time traveller and his desire is
to bring Emma back. He makes Alex hallucinate
about his life if Emma hadn’t died. He is filled
with sadness, to see Emma and his kid playing.
The leader then concludes that humans cannot
change fate, because they are the results of their
own actions. Then, he shows Alex the time machine
that he had brought into the Morlock world.
The leader wants him to go back to where he came
from, and not harm the balance of the society now.
Alex quietly obliges but as he starts the
machine, he pulls the leader in with him.
The two struggle for a while. Alex holds him
outside the machine’s sphere and starts it.
The leader dies rapidly by ageing. He again
stops the machine in the future and sees the
place is filled with Morlock’s cave, suggesting
that the place is now ruled by Morlocks.
Alex then comes back to save Mara,
and brings her out of the cage.
The Morlocks get angry and leap to attack
them, but Alex jams a gear in the machine,
creating a massive distortion in time. The time
machine explodes taking all of Morlock's world
with it, but Mara and Alex manage to run out of
the cave just in time. With his time machine gone,
Alex decides to stay with Elois
as he has found satisfaction here.
In the future, we see Vox 144 teaching
Elois children about the past of humans.
Alex brings Muri and Kalen to the place, where his
lab used to be. As he talks to them, somewhere in
another time, David and Mrs. Watchit enter Alex’s
lab and discuss his disappearance. David claims
that Alex is happy wherever he is, and offers
Mrs. Watchit to come work as his housekeeper.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a like
to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.